at jr the boss man the nba is a virtual
lock to expand to las vegas and seattle
what markets are in the conversation as
it pertains to potential nfl expansion
well i'll say this jr the boss man
the conversation about potential nfl
expansion hasn't happened yet i think
the nfl is looking at this in a linear
fashion first
they got to 17 games next they'll get to
18 games
they won't be able to increase the
inventory of total games beyond 18.
so the only way to increase the
inventory of total games
after you get to an 18 game season is to
expand the number of teams
more teams more games
i would suspect that cities that have
successfully hosted nfl teams in the
past would be in the mix now
the lawsuit filed by st louis against
the nfl set to go to trial
by the way uh
right about the time the super bowl
happens in la where the rams moved
i think st louis at some point would
potentially be in play and maybe a
settlement
would include some sort of favored
nation status for st
louis in the event that there's
expansion in the future that's
part of the deal that averted litigation
when the browns
left cleveland back in 1995. i'd say san
diego to the extent that someone's going
to build a stadium there without
taxpayer dollars
i would say and and this whole chicago
arlington heights stadium thing has gone
from
not even a whisper to a roar in just a
few weeks
the bears are going to build their own
stadium state of the art
maximum revenue streams number three
market
in the nation the number one market has
two teams
the number two market has two teams i
think chicago
would be a potential site either for
relocation or expansion and also london
al michaels said 10 years ago when the
league goes back to los
angeles it will be two teams not one i
think there's room
for two teams in london and i think if
the nfl over does go to london it will
be two teams
whether it's expansion or whether it's
an expansion team and
a current team maybe a current team that
plays in london
every single year uh hey and i i know
folks in jacksonville you're not happy
to hear that but
i'm not the one who's decided that the
jaguars are going to play a home game in
london every year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports